et je m'apprête maintenant à remettre le
très attendu césar du meilleur premier
film
oui c'est moi qui remet parce que bon
y'a plus de patrons dont ceux je fais ce
que je veux c'est pas une intérim qui va
m'arrêter bien alors par contre ne vous
inquiétez pas attention je suis pro je
me suis préparée depuis très longtemps
enfin je veux dire je ne fais pas les
choses comme sa dernière minute j'ai
j'ai vraiment bossé c'est à dire que par
souci de neutralité
j'ai choisi de le visionner aucun des
films de la sélection je ne venais pas
foutu un pied au cinéma de toute l'année
rassurez-vous et oui non mais c'est un
choix c'est pas une question de volonté
mais quelle volonté il a fallu qu'elle
volonté il a fallu pour pas allez allez
voir papicha et au nom de la terre au
mk2 bibliothèque à un soir de pluie en
plein hiver sur mon petit vélo
électrique
on n'est pas content j'ai lutté contre
vents et marées sont restés sous ma
couette j'ai dit non tu attends crève
d'envié mais tu reste bien sûr et je
n'ai pas non plus regarder les dvd du
coffret ah non non non et ça l'a annoncé
c'est pas parce que j'étais sur netflix
ocs amazon ou my canal toute la sainte
journée cela elle voit rien à voir avec
mon addiction instagram c'est pareil
c'est ça c'est parce que je n'ai pas
trouvé de lecteurs de dvd
ah non mais j'ai cherché dans tout paris
attend un bon coin il bet ou bordel puis
on n'y a plus un seul lecteur si on l'a
trouvé un chez jean claude brialy mais
il en péritel il fait pas usage d amy
donc j'ai pas fais mes résultats je suis
neutre
voilà merci donc du coup qui mieux que
moi pour remettre ce césar